hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on down appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become let's face it sometimes life
as a student can be hectic and when
you're living away from home you may be
restricted to very limited cooking
utensils hence you feel like you can't
be healthy although you're trying really
hard to I'm going to show you how as a
student you can still eat healthy using
very basic kitchen utensils and cooking
ingredients plus you don't need any
cooking skills because trust me I barely
knew anything when I was a student
this meal prep only required to have
ingredients to make breakfast lunch and
dinner for a total of three days the
chopped ingredients are bread tortilla
soba or rice noodles tomato paste black
beans corn carrots bell pepper chicken
leg onions eggs and cheese as students I
know that we always want to have a
variety especially when it comes to our
meals so remember these ingredients can
be easily replaced with something else
as long as you have the basis of the
recipes right I'm super excited about
breakfast because we're making pizza
bread yes I personally used to make this
when I was a student living in a school
hostel it's really simple plus the idea
of having pizza for breakfast is great
only four ingredients two slices of
homeo bread two hard-boiled eggs tomato
paste and cheese now let's start by
prepping the eggs boil them until they
are hard once the eggs are ready
thinly slice using an egg slicer then
spread about one tablespoon of tomato
paste evenly over each slice of bread
and top it up with the sliced eggs
finally sprinkle some cheese on top just
about 1 tablespoon on both if you have a
toaster oven
simply bake for 5 to 7 minutes until the
cheese is melted and the bread toasted
if not you can also place it onto a pan
and allow the bread to toast then cover
it for a couple of minutes until the
cheese melts well if you know that
you're always in a morning rush to go
for your classes
then boil lots of eggs the day before
and store them in the fridge for up to
three days all you have to do in the
morning is to assemble this dish which
takes less than 10 minutes egg is a
power food because it is a great source
of protein just consuming 2 eggs in the
morning you're already getting 12 grams
of protein you want to be having protein
in the morning because it helps to keep
you full and satisfied
this means no snacking in between plus
you get to stay focused throughout your
morning classes it's lunchtime I'm going
to keep it really simple
and here this you don't even have to
cook you can prep ahead and pack this
with you to school we're making vegan
black bean and corn wrap for this you'll
need tortillas one can of black beans
washed and drained 1/3 cup of corn
washed and drained 1 red bell pepper 1/2
an onion and tomato paste start by
dicing the onion and bell pepper then in
a bowl simply mix all the ingredients
together I'm going to season it with a
little bit of salt and pepper to
assemble grab one tortilla and spread
about one tablespoon of tomato paste
onto it then scoop about a quarter cup
of the mixed ingredients and spread it
onto one side of the tortilla now
carefully and gently roll it up and
press it down firmly
you can have about two tortilla wraps
for lunch and I like to serve mine with
more sliced up vegetables on the side
what I like to do is prep the mixed
ingredients and store it in the fridge
for up to three days and when I want to
have it all I have to do is assemble it
into a wrap that way I'm always keeping
my lunch fresh and what I like about
this recipe is that you can simply
change up the ingredients for instance
use tuna chickpeas or even chicken
breasts and the same goes to the
vegetables choose cucumber cherry
tomatoes olives or carrots as for dinner
let's make a hearty bowl of soup noodles
from my version we're going to add in a
lot of protein and also vegetables and
instead of cooking instant noodles which
are mostly deep-fried let's go for much
healthier noodles such as soba rice or
sweet potato noodles and guess what
these noodles are also gluten free for
my students I'm using one whole chicken
leg half a carrot a quarter of an onion
a quarter of a red bell pepper 2
tablespoons of corn 2 ounces of soba
noodles and an egg slice up all the
vegetables in a pot saute the onion with
about 1 TSP of sesame oil until fragrant
and slightly golden brown then pour in
about one and a half cups of water and
simply add in the ingredients chicken
leg carrots and corn I'm gonna season it
with a little bit of salt and pepper let
it simmer until the chicken leg is fully
cooked through then stir in the soba
noodles and bell pepper and allow it to
cook for another 2 to 3 minutes until
the noodles are done soup noodles always
taste so much better with an egg so I'm
going to crack an egg stir it and let it
cook for another minute I love an eggy
broth voila
dinner is ready this is a one pot dish
which has protein cups and lots of
vegetables so no fussing about in the
kitchen by trying to cook too
different dishes you can't keep changing
your protein by using fish beef pork or
even beans now if you like a stronger
broth taste you can simply add a little
bit of chicken or vegetable stock into
your cooking listen up no more excuses
for not eating healthy even if you're
living on your own try all these recipes
and let me know which is a favorite in
the comments below and do check out
other really simple a healthy student
recipes on my youtube channel so be sure
to give this video a thumbs up like this
video and share this video with your
friends and don't forget to hashtag me
and tag me in your post all the best